What happens when the Lockes come face to
face with their new foe?
And will Tyler return home to help his family?
Here's what you need to know before you watch
the final season of "Locke and Key."
Season 3 of "Locke & Key" has been in production
for quite some time, and it had actually been
written before Season 2 even premiered.
Producer Carlton Cuse explained to Collider,
"It was actually a really weird thing that
I've never experienced in my career, to have
written a full season of television that hadn't
been made, and we had to go on to writing
the next season of television."
Season 3 was also shot back to back with Season
2, meaning that filming wrapped in September
2021, a month before Season 2 hit Netflix.
Connor Jessup, who plays Tyler Locke on the
show, posted a series of behind-the-scenes
snaps on Instagram, and wrote,
"that's a wrap on season 3 of locke & key.
after a year of shooting, we're done.
I'm a tangled mess [...] I'm sleepy and happy
and sad.
but mostly, I'm grateful.
it's been a weird, sh—- year and this show
has been a refuge."
Thankfully, fans won't have to wait too long
for Netflix to drop Season 3.
Netflix has been teasing "Locke and Key" Season
3 on social media since the end of 2021, but
has been cagey with release details until
now.
During Netflix's Geeked Week event, the streamer
shared a trailer for Season 3 and revealed
that the series will return on August 10,
2022.
"Locke & Key" Season 3 will air a mere 10
months after Season 2, compared to the 20-month
wait fans endured between the first and second
seasons.
This highly anticipated season will reportedly
consist of eight episodes, which is a departure
from the previous 10-episode format.
Hopefully, this shorter season is still able
to mirror the success of the previous season,
which was streamed for more than 143 million
hours globally during its first four weeks
on Netflix.
Now that Netflix has announced the release
date for Season 3, fans are clamoring to know
if their favorite characters will return for
the next installment of "Locke and Key."
Thankfully, most of the show's main actors
have confirmed they'll be returning.
Connor Jessup was one of the first actors
to reaffirm his place in the series, even
though his character Tyler Locke leaves to
go traveling at the end of Season 2.
Jessup told Decider in October 2021,
"I don't think when he leaves at the end of
Season 2 that his story is over [...] To me,
it felt like a new chapter, but it didn't
feel like a resolution.
So, there's still more for Tyler."
Jessup will be joined by Emilia Jones and
Jackson Robert Scott, who play his younger
siblings, Kinsey and Bode.
Darby Stanchfield will also be returning as
their mom, Nina Locke, along with Aaron Ashmore,
who plays Duncan, the Locke childrens' uncle.
Meanwhile, Sherri Saum, who plays Ellie, has
been promoted to series regular, which means
we might also see more of Coby Bird, who plays
her son Rufus.
Kevin Durand will also be getting more screen
time as the Revolutionary War soldier Captain
Frederick Gideon.
The dramatic second season of "Locke & Key"
came to a conclusion at the same time as Matheson
Academy's fall semester.
At the end of the season finale, Nina reveals
that Tyler is going traveling over the winter
break because he needs a fresh start.
However, the trailer for Season 3 places Tyler
squarely in the middle of all the action alongside
his family, so viewers can expect some time
to have elapsed between the second and third
seasons.
This means that the earliest the series could
be set is the beginning of the spring semester,
with Tyler returning to finish his education.
However, it's also possible that more time
has passed, taking viewers to the end of the
summer semester and Tyler's last few weeks
at Matheson Academy.
Alternatively, there could be less of a school
focus this season and the show could be set
entirely during the summer holidays, giving
the Locke family plenty of time to deal with
the show's latest villain.
For the last two seasons, "Locke & Key" has
had a revolving door of villains and antagonists.
However, in Season 3, Tyler, Kinsey, Bode,
Nina, and Duncan will be facing a new villain,
and that's Frederick Gideon.
"Who the hell are you?"
"Your captain."
This Revolutionary War captain played by Kevin
Durand made his debut in flashbacks seen during
the first episode of Season 2.
He appeared in a total of four episodes, which
explain his backstory and how a demon took
over his body when he found the Black Door
in the sea caves.
In the last episode of Season 2, the demon
inhabiting Eden's body brought Captain Gideon
back as an echo, initially unaware that a
demon was also inhabiting his body.
After throwing Eden into the well, Gideon
left with the Anywhere Key.
During a roundtable interview, showrunner
Carlton Cuse explained that Durand's character
will be a deadly threat to the Locke family,
saying,
"Meredith and I were faced with the challenge
of how [do] we up the stakes [...] and come
up with a source of villainy that would feel
like an escalation and also be compelling.
That led us to create this character of Gideon
and Kevin seemed like the perfect guy to play
him."
One of the biggest changes going into Season
3 of "Locke & Key" is that Tyler has no memory
of the magic he and his siblings discovered
at Keyhouse.
In the final episode of Season 2, Tyler leaves
to go traveling.
"The past is always with us.
You can try to run away."
He plans to return after his 18th birthday
with no memory of magic, despite having spent
most of the season searching for the Memory
Key, which would allow him to remember magic
as an adult.
Instead, he tells his siblings that he wants
to live a normal life after his birthday and
opts not to remember magic.
After all, magic caused the death of his dad
and his girlfriend, becoming a major source
of emotional trauma for him.
"I want to have a normal life."
However, it seems like a magic-free life might
not be in the cards for Tyler, especially
with Captain Gideon lurking in the shadows.
And Tyler certainly appears to have his memories
back in the trailer.
"Locke & Key" has always been a very family-oriented
show.
However, the events of the Season 2 finale
have seen some significant changes that will
affect the Locke family dynamic.
Plus, Tyler's bonds with his siblings will
undoubtedly change after he forgets about
magic.
Meanwhile, Nina will probably grow closer
to her children now that she knows about magic,
as it has been a barrier between them in previous
seasons.
Essentially, Season 3 will focus on how the
Lockes navigate these changes and come together
to face Captain Gideon.
As showrunner Meredith Averill teased to Collider,
"The third season focuses much more heavily
on the family.
They're gonna face the greatest threat they've
had to face yet.
That really bonds them in a way that we've
never seen before.
I can't say more than that."
Kinsey and Scot finally getting together is
something viewers of the show had been waiting
for, ever since their budding romance was
dashed after Gabe swooped in and grabbed Kinsey's
attention.
Of course, Gabe turned out to be the evil
demon echo Dodge, so that relationship was
pretty much doomed from the start.
As Kinsey started to uncover Gabe's true identity,
she and Scot fell for each other again, but
their timing wasn't great.
Season 2 concluded with the couple about to
embark on a long-distance relationship as
Scot chose to attend film school in London
for a year before going to college.
However, Scot's nickname for Kinsey is rocky
road, and that could be what the couple are
in for in Season 3.
In fact, Netflix has yet to confirm if Petrice
Jones, who plays Scot, is returning for the
third season, and he doesn't appear in the
trailer.
Other cast members have posted behind-the-scenes
photos from the new season on Instagram, but
Jones is strangely missing from the snaps.
That said, it's very possible Jones' return
to the show is just being kept under wraps
for dramatic effect, and Kinsey and Scot will
end up back together in Season 3.
"I'm here, you know, if you need me."
While Petrice Jones' return is up in the air,
another Locke love interest is definitely
due back in Matheson for Season 3.
Brendan Hines will once again be featured
as Nina's on-again-off-again partner Josh
Bennett.
The pair left their relationship up in the
air last season.
When Josh told Nina he finally felt able to
move on from his wife's death and commit to
her properly, she shut him down.
In the season finale, Nina explained that
she wasn't ready, and told him she needed
more time before they could be together.
However, they certainly left things open-ended,
with the possibility for their relationship
to blossom in Season 3.
However, if Nina and Josh do rekindle their
romance, the fact that she knows about magic
might make things a bit more difficult for
them going forward.
It's always exciting when a "Locke & Key"
character reveals a new magical key, and thankfully
there's more excitement to come in Season
3.
Duncan now has the ability to make keys, which
is a good skill to have with a supervillain
on the loose.
According to the comics created by Joe Hill,
there are still plenty of keys left for the
Lockes to find and the trailer introduces
a pretty major one.
It looks like Bode discovers the Timeshift
Key, allowing users to see visions of the
past when used in the Lockes' grandfather
clock.
This could certainly come in handy as the
Locke family try to discover more about Captain
Gideon's past in order to defeat him.
It also might come into play for Tyler when
he gets his memories back, as he could see
visions of his past self using magic.
"This key.
This key can make it so you never forget."
Season 2 also introduced a lot of new keys
to the show, in addition to the ones established
in the first season.
Fans are certainly eager to see more keys
like the Angel Key, which Kinsey used in the
finale and was instrumental in helping to
defeat Dodge.
Season 3 will be the Locke family's last paranormal
adventure on Netflix.
The show hasn't been canceled, though, as
it was always the plan to end the story after
three seasons.
According to co-showrunners Carlton Cuse and
Meredith Averill, "Locke & Key" will naturally
reach its conclusion at the end of Season
3, with the duo telling Deadline in a statement,
"Once we began working on the series, we felt
three seasons was the ideal length to bring
the story of the Locke family and their Keyhouse
adventures to a satisfying conclusion."
They also sang the praises of writer Joe Hill
and illustrator Gabriel Rodriguez, who created
the "Locke and Key" comic book series, and
joked,
"We're keeping the magical keys, though, for
our own personal use."
Since Cuse and Averill have been planning
the conclusion of "Locke & Key" since the
end of Season 1, they should have the opportunity
to tie up all of the show's loose threads.
So, here's hoping fans get everything they
want to see and more in Season 3 of "Locke
& Key."
The "Locke & Key" showrunners have been keeping
quiet about a lot of the particulars in the
upcoming season, but the trailer does reveal
a few extra details for fans.
For one, it looks like Gideon is creating
an army.
While his motives aren't clear, the trailer
suggests he's coming for the keys, and possibly
even Keyhouse itself.
However, Gideon's evil plans appear to culminate
in a big battle between his army and the Lockes.
"This is our house.
Those keys belong to us."
Viewers can definitely expect to see an epic
showdown as Tyler, Kinsey, Bode, Nina, and
Duncan defend their home and the keys in the
battle to end all battles.
This fight promises to be a satisfying and
dramatic conclusion to the final season of
"Locke & Key."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.